oh
who frowned me this face
[Music]
take two doctor who review where i
re-review
episodes of the modern arrow doctor who
that i have in fact
reviewed previously long freaking time
ago
let's see how they hold up on a re-watch
so we have arrived at the debut
proper of peter capaldi the 12th doctor
my favorite doctor let's just get that
on the record
now in case you are watching this but
weren't aware of that
beard capaldi is my favorite iteration
of the doctor
at present i say at present because it
has changed before
it may change again it's changed a few
times over the years but
right now that's where it is and it's
worth noting that
i didn't love him right off i didn't
dislike him but i didn't connect with
the guy
immediately i'm not gonna dwell dwell on
this too much
but i what really got me about him is
the journey that his doctor went through
series over series he to me
felt like he had more of an arc than
nearly
then actually i would say then more than
any other doctor
most doctors don't have an ark at all
and the ones that do
i don't think any of them went through
as much of a personal transformation
as capaldi's 12th doctor so part of what
i love about him is where he
ended up by the end of series 10 but
also watching him go through that
from the from where he started through
to the end
so it's interesting for me now to go
back and watch it
knowing how much i'm going to grow to
love him and it does give me a fresh
perspective on this
i've i've been i don't think i've been
mean but i haven't exactly been kind to
deep breath in the past
i don't think i've been too harsh on it
but it's
i have never sung its praises but it was
interesting for me to watch it this time
and knowing how i'm going to feel more
about some of the things that i'm seeing
at play
now like also already knowing who missy
is and knowing that i freaking love
missy
so i actually think
that deep breath is better on a re-watch
because the mystery and suspenseful
elements
to me at the time that they were
introduced didn't mean a lot
at the time that she was introduced
missy was just
oh i guess this is what they're going to
build the mystery box around
who's missy what's with the heaven
and give now that's me in the mystery
box season arcs
i just don't i was i was done with them
by now i was ready for them to be
done so that's all she was to me when
she was first introduced
and capaldi's doctor i didn't quite have
a grip on yet and
watching him here knowing how he's going
to be later
it puts it into a new context so it's
not a matter of
i'm worried that i won't get on this
doctor's wavelength it's more of a oh
right
he's starting all the way over there and
i'm gonna get to watch him end up over
here so
this i actually find a lot more
enjoyable on a re-watch
whether you want to consider that a
positive or a negative given that
it's not that in a vacuum watching the
second time makes it better but
knowing everything that happens later
retroactively on a re-watch makes it
better
you could actually consider that a fault
of the episode in and of itself in some
ways because it really should stand
better on an initial
viewing and it shouldn't require
a revisit to see more good in it
even though i do so you know a little
bit conflicted on that
so let's talk about some of the
specifics of what we've got here
capaldi write off big focus on the
grumpy
which he's very good at
and there there are some scenes that are
really brilliant for that
him in that alleyway the whole who
frowned me this face
and his realization that he's scottish
and he can be really cross and complain
about things
like that was that was great i love that
there's a really wonderful moment and i
liked
this perspective on the idea of
one one of the reasons possibly why the
doctor
has this face because clara is confused
that he
regenerated it's a refreshed life but he
looks older why does he look
older if this is a new fresh life
and i like madame vastra comparing it to
her veil that when she goes out she
wears
you know madame vastra wears the veil to
cover the fact that she's
a lizard and when she's out in public so
that
people will accept her and the doctor
wore the face of a younger man
to be more accepted and
him letting himself look
older is him removing the veil and
letting her
see him a little bit more nakedly
i also like that it's that that is a
perspective that's coming from
vastra which makes it her interpretation
of what's happening because
that's one of those and i i talk about
this with doctor who from time to time
it's one of those things where
i like that interpretation but if you
don't
if you think that's bs you don't have to
take that on board for your own head
cannon
because it's not coming from the doctor
it's coming from another character and
it's what she thinks about the doctor
you can agree or disagree
i don't even know if i agree with that
assessment that she gives but i think
it's a neat idea all the same and it was
nice to hear it vocalized
um so since i brought up vastra vastra
jenny strikes peter nostergang
um pretty decently used they're fun here
strax has some good
some good moments him playing off of
clara and just
you know continuing to to call her boy
and you know talking to
her about getting the doctor back and
then we will dissolve him in
acid uh strax no and then we will not
dissolve him in acid i'm like oh god
he's ridiculous but like as long as it's
not about him being dumb
so like the pratt fall towards the end
could it you know jenny and vastra
descend
gracefully like like ribbon dancing
ninjas and he just falls that gag i
could have done without because that
felt
more like he's dumb um but gags like the
dissolved
acid like that's wow love that
um some of the stuff with vassar as much
as i like that conversation that i just
said about the veil the whole fact that
you know they cut away and they come
back and her veil is off and
clara's like when did you remove the
veil and she said when you stopped
needing to see it or something to that
effect i'm like that was unlike if they
were gonna have it just not be there i
would rather they had not
drawn attention to it and just do it and
let the moment speak for itself
um the okay i need to touch
on the t-rex because
even on a re-watch even trying to to
come at it from a perspective where it's
not going to bother me so much
i still really don't
like the fact that the t-rex is
burned alive that really
bothers me um and
it's kind of dumb i don't mean that the
t-rex burns alive
but the fact that the t-rex burns alive
is actually kind of lazy
the fact that i that it bothers me as
much as it does is kind of dumb
i'm copying to that so the thing about
this
is i here's what i will grant
i will grant that the doctor himself
has a proper appreciation of how awful
this is
so it does help that at least one
character
is feeling that weight
of how cruel and unnecessary this was
but the fact that it is so cruel and
unnecessary and i don't just mean on the
part of the villains i mean on the part
of the writer
or the part of stephen moffat that's
what i don't like
because you can make whatever argument
you want to
to me about it showing what the villains
were capable of or
what have you none of that was necessary
because we already knew that
we had already seen implied that
you know the the they were stripping
parts out of
human beings we could have had some
something else lead them onto the
spontaneous combustion thing other than
the dinosaur
the reason it happens
is the same reason that say
the tritivores die in
planet of the dead because to
resolve them or the t-rex in any other
way
eats up screen time that the writer has
decided he doesn't want to bother
doing so they just kill it
and that is lazy
and cruel so there's
there is barely a narrative
justification
for the t-rex going up in flames and i
don't think it needed to be the t-rex in
order for
it to do that but the reason it was the
t-rex
was because moffat didn't want to have
to figure out how to deal with this
thing
so just burn it up now it's not a
dangling plot thread anymore i don't
have to worry about it
i just
it just feels cruel re-watching it it
just
feels cruel for me to watch and i don't
enjoy that
i really don't
i probably get way more hung up on that
than it's justified but like she
she didn't deserve that
she was she was scared and lonely
and the doctor recognized that which i
appreciate for him in terms of his
showing an ability to have empathy which
is something he's going to have issues
with at other points
but damn moffett
come on anyways
clara's actually pretty good in this one
and see
i i've said this before clara rubbed me
the wrong way
when she was first introduced to series
seven because she is more of a plot
device
than a character she was the impossible
girl before she was the companion
i don't just mean like the order of
things like in terms of the
the ranking the importance of what she
was in the story
impossible girl companion she was way
more important as a plot device than she
was as a character she was just
filling she just happened to be filling
that role so
now that the impossible girl thing is
over
she feels much more
like a character and less like a plot
device
and it also helps that i am personally
of the opinion that her chemistry
with capaldi even at this early stage is
better than the chemistry she had with
smith
so i'm i this is where i started
enjoying clara moore
seeing her bounce off of him and
especially with capaldi because he
irritates her and but he's so blunt
at her at the same time that he you know
he winds her up and
she bites back at him i i i like that
dynamic
i i think they have a fun bicker
not all bickering is fun but i find
their bickering to
be fun and enjoyable the
thing with the aliens and sort of the
bringing back and referencing
the clockwork robots from girl in the
fireplace
it's fine i don't really have strong
feelings one way or the other on that
there isn't really a a particularly
strong connection
or reason for there to be that
connection but also doesn't hurt
anything
you know for for what they needed the
villains to be doing for the narrative
to work
you can fit that in the mold of the
clockwork
droids so why not have it be kind of a
return of them
there's no reason for it not to be so
yeah
sure it doesn't blow me away i don't
love it but
yeah hey that works cool
the introduction of missy it is just
that it is just
oh don't you wonder who this is i enjoy
it more because
i now know who it is and i know how much
i love
love missy again though a bit
a bit put going too much on the nose
with the thing a bit like
vastra having to draw attention to the
fact that she had lifted the veil
having missy actually asked the question
did you jump or did he push you i
couldn't tell i'm like
the mo we okay we just had that moment
we watched it and we got to not know
so why are you pointing out in dialogue
the thing that we just watched the
ambiguity
why i have slightly mixed feelings
about that moment as well
um i suppose it was just kind of a way
to tease out
you know how different is this doctor
in terms of what he is or isn't willing
to do in his own moral compass
which i suppose is fair enough but the
idea of
is he more willing to take a life in
like direct action feels like a
kind of a cheap way to to build that
tension
especially when they did it much better
earlier in the same episode
by having him appear to abandon clara
and like did that tension there really
well
and you yes he comes back and he rescues
her but he did
still leave her in a situation where she
might have died
and that's the situation where like is
he getting
careless is he trusting her too much is
he not
appreciating the danger that he's
putting her in what happened there
that gives us tension that gives us
reason to question
and have some doubts about this doctor
without having to have it be
did he push this guy or did the guy jump
like
you you had a much more organic and
interesting version of that same
question already
and then you do it again and then you
have missy actually vocalize it out loud
why there's no need for that pacing on
this is also a little weird
because it's an extra long episode like
it's it's longer than some of the
specials it's an
hour 15. i'm not entirely sure
why there's nothing about the plot or
the progression that
needs extra time and i'm not sure that
it really
does all that much to take advantage of
it there are
there are some scenes that i would
actually say drag on a little too long
as much as i love it
the scene in the alley where you know
who found me this face
that goes on a little too long probably
by
about a minute or so about a minute
longer than it needs to be and there's a
couple of other scenes like that
there's other scenes that are that are
cute um
you know bits that are fine that i think
would have been cut out of a tighter
story
but their being here don't add that much
it doesn't have enough
breathing room to have the more relaxed
pace
of like a feature length would have you
know the breathing room for
um for more downtime and whatnot but it
it so it does it's not enough extra time
for it to have
that but at the same time it it's not
like filling it in with anything that
that's a bit more punchy or anything
like that so
i'm not sure why they felt the need to
make it this long other than just
trying to give capaldi a big debut i
suppose
um oh the breath holding scene
that was good and a lot of that was down
to
jenna coleman's performance her
like the little lurches when like her
body
instinctively wants to draw breath and
she's forcing it to not
do that and this this
determination on her face
and that that's a tense scene that was
really well done actually props to them
for that
that that was something that i was quite
impressed with i kind of forgotten how
tense that scene is
uh the when they revisit it towards the
end when
in the fight scene it's not quite as
potent
um but that first time when it's just
clara oh yeah
oh yeah that's tense stuff
i think that's about everything i wanted
to hit
like i said there's a lot of little
moments that i like there's a couple of
things that don't really
matter but bother me and
moffat he seems to be having moments
where
he's either not trusting the audience or
he's not trusting his writing
i'm not sure which it is he's either not
trusting his writing to have conveyed
everything
or he's not trusting his audience to
keep up with him
and things are just being hit a little
more on the nose than they need to be
and reiterate it a little bit more than
is necessary especially get
considering we're going to get three
full series of this guy you don't need
to hit this hard on everything right off
the bat
but it's solid it's not bad it is a
decent first outing for the doctor
and it gives us a little bit of a taste
of this doctor and it it helps that
he is trying to figure himself out as
well because
there's always a certain element of that
but i would argue that
especially tenant and smith they kind of
came out fully formed like they would
have lines that said i'm figuring out
who i am but they seem to be pretty
confident and stayed
pretty true to the characterization we
saw of them in their very first
appearance for the
entire run whereas capaldi seems way
more
uneasy not quite solid in his footing
trying to figure himself out you know
even when clara hugs him
and he says i don't think i'm a hugging
person like he isn't even sure
about that i do appreciate that
oh the one other thing the the moment
with matt smith
calling i'm of two minds about on the
one hand and i remember it being like a
point of debate at the time
it felt like it was undercutting
capaldi's debut
by immediately going like oh remember
remember the guy we just got rid of that
you miss
like are you shooting yourself in the
foot a little bit
by by by making that comparison all the
stronger
and i can see that argument but i i do
think the moment is kind of tender
and it it does make sense that it kind
of helps with the transition
for clara and there's also something
about
and maybe it's just the direction that
my own life has taken
in the last few years but something
about
capaldi's line you don't see me
you look at me and you don't see me yeah
i
uh i feel that
so if for no other reason i like that
scene because we get that line
deep breath you rewatched it lately
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments and
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do
like subscribe all that sort of things i
have a patreon naturally doesn't
everyone
and you can support and help grow the
channel and uh
i also have a podcast a bunch of other
things links in the description
no pressure though because end of the
day you're the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]